[موسيقى]
ثم طابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى بانوراما
وهذه عناوينها
حاد في اسرائيل هل سببه التعديلات
القضائيه فقط ام ان الازمه اكبر واعقد من
ذلك
[موسيقى]
المخاوف من تفكك الجيش والخطر على الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي مبالغات لاهداف سياسيه
ام واقع قابل للتحقيق
[موسيقى]
ما هي السيناريوهات المطروحه والتداعيات
المتوقعه لما يجري في اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله بعد نحو 12 اسبوعا من
التظاهرات العامه في ساحات تل ابيب وغيرها
من المدن الاسرائيليه يشعر المتظاهرون
الاسرائيليون انهم باتوا قريبين من
التحقيق مطلبهم بوقف الحكومه الاسرائيليه
التعديلات القضائيه في محاولته لاحتواء
الموقف اخبرنا نتنياهو قاده الائتلاف عزمه
تعليق التعديلات القضائيه التي اشعلت
شراره احتجاجات غير مسبوقه على الاطلاق في
اسرائيل رغم معرفته بموقف المحتجين الرافض
لتعليق التعديلات القضائيه والسعي الى
الغائها بل ورفع رئيس المعارضه يا
ايرلابيد من المطالب وشدد بخطابه واسطه
حماس المحتجين في القدس الى ان الاحتجاجات
تسعى لوضع دستور مكتوب للبلاد وامام هذه
التطورات المربكه لرئيس الحكومه يغادر
وزير الامن الداخلي اتمارا
اجتماع الحكومه ليطالب انصاره بالخروج
بتظاهرات مضاده في القدس والتي يحتشد فيها
اصلا 80 الف متظاهر في محيط الكنيست وفق
الشرطه الاسرائيليه التي لجات لاتخاذ
تدابير امنيه كبيره تحسبا لوقوع مواجهات
بين المحتجين وبين انصار اليمين
الاضرابات تشل الحياه في اسرائيل
اتحاد النقابات واتحاد اصحاب العمل يعلنان
اضرابا عن العمل اغلاق المطار والموانئ
والمستشفيات والمتاجر العمل يتوقف في
المصانع والورش
العاملون والموظفون في الشوارع وتل ابيب
مغلقه
عشرات الاف المحتجين يطوقون الكنيست في
القدس
شوارع المدينه المركزيه اغلقت
تعليمات للسفارات الاسرائيليه في انحاء
العالم بالانضمام الى اضراب الاثنين
ينضم الينا من تل ابيب بعد دبلوماسيه سابق
اسحاق ليبانون ومن تل ابيب ايضا روفين
باركو امني سابق ومحاضر ومن الناصر عبر
زوم وديع عواوده الكاتب السياسي وينضم
الينا كذلك من تل ابيب الدونسي السابق اذا
كما ذكرنا اسحاق ليبانون لاسالك اولا
بدايه ما الذي يحدث الان في الشارع والى
اين تتجه الامور اليوم
والابوط تتجه اليوم بعد اعلان سنسمعه من
رئيس الوزراء
الى تهدئه الاوضاع الى وقف التعديلات
الفضائيه الذي كانت الحكومه تريد ان تقوم
بها لتهدئه الاوضاع لمده او الفتى معينه
وبعد ذلك وبعد مرور الاعياد في اسرائيل
الفصح وعيد الاستقلال
واخر
الحفلات في اسرائيل
سيكون هنالك حديث بين الاطراف سواء كان من
طرف واحد ومن طرف الثاني ربما في
مكتب رئيس الدوله لكي نتقدم باتجاه تفاهم
او تساوم بعد جميع
وابرام وتعديل هذه
المواقف القضائيه
بدعم من كل المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذا هو
الاتجاه علينا ان ننتظر
لكي يقوم هذا الاتجاه سننتظر ونناقش اكثر
لنعرف حقيقه الوضع وهذا سؤالي الى السيده
روفين باركو الامنيه السابق والمحاضر سيد
يعني اليوم حال الانقسام في اسرائيل هل هي
حال ربما اعتاد عليها بسبب
يقول عنها الاسرائيليون انها الديمقراطيه
وضريبه الديمقراطيه ام ان هذه المره هذا
الحال غير مسبوق نهائيا
[موسيقى]
كل واحد
الام الحقيقيه للطفل
ان ياتوه
الى النصف
النساء كانت مستعده ان يتم ذلك والثانيه
واليوم ايضا
هذا الانقسام الوطني يدعون بانهم على حق
[موسيقى]
شرخ عميق بين شقي الشعب وانا انصت تماما
لمخاوف واريد ان اخفف التوتر
ان يكون هناك اقليه متطرفه
تريد ان تقطع هذه الدوله اربا
تستخدم العنف تشعل النيران
تهدد بالم
س بخبيئه الجمهور
ويحرض وتحرض على حرب اهليه وتنادي من
اجرفت الخدمه العسكريه وهذه جريمه فظيعه
دوله اسرائيل يمكن ان تبقى دون الجيش
الاسرائيلي والجيش الاسرائيلي لا يمكن ان
يبقى في ظل رفض الخدمه العسكريه رفض
الخدمه العسكريه ستقود من جهه الى رفض
الخدمه من الطرف الاخر رفض الخدمه
العسكريه هي نهايه دولتنا لذلك انا اطالب
انا اطالب من قاده الاجهزه الامنيه ومن
قاده الجيش ان يعارضوا وبكل شده ظاهره رفض
الخدمه العسكريه عدم استيعابها عدم تفهمها
وعدم تقبلها
ولكن ايقافها
هؤلاء الذين ينادون برفض الخدمه العسكريه
اولئك الذين ينادون من اجل الفوضى وللعنف
يقومون ببتر الجنين
لكن الغالبيه العظمى من مواطنين دوله
اسرائيل من طرفي الصراع لا يردون بطر
الجنين هم ليسوا مستعدون لتمزيق الشعب
مواطنوا اسرائيل
انا لست مستعد لتمزيق الشعب
اعلى مدار ثلاثه اشهر الماره تلو الاخرى
ناديت للحوار وقلت
انني ساقلب كل حجر من اجل الوصول الى حل
لانني اذكر
ونحن نذكر جميعنا
اننا لا نقف امام اعداء نحن نقف امام
اشقاء
وانا اقول هنا والان
لا يجب ان تحصل حرب اهليه نحن موجودون في
مسار
صدام خطير في المجتمع الاسرائيلي نحن
موجودون في اوج ازمه تهدد الوحده الاساسيه
فيما بيننا اسمك هذه ازمه هذه تتطلب منا
جميعنا ان نتصرف مسؤوليه امس
قرات رساله بينيجانس والتي يتعهد فيها
ليدخل في مفاوضات بنيه جيده بشان
التشريعات واعرف ان هناك من يؤيد هذا وامد
لهم يد واقوم بذلك بعد ان حصلت على موافقه
غالبيه زملائي
حينما توجد فرصه لمنع الحرب الاليه عبر
الحوار
انا كرئيس للحكومه اخذ
من اجل الحوار واعطي فرصه من اجل حوار
حقيقي
نحن نصر على ضروره ادخال التشريعات
المطلوبه في المنظومه القضائيه وسنعطي
الفرصه من اجل الوصول الى هذه التعديلات
باجماع واسع هذا هدف سامي لذلك من خلال
المسؤوليه الوطنيه ومن خلال الرغبه عدم
التعميق الشرق في قررت ارجاء
تقديم
قانون تعديل لجنه القضاه في هذه الدوره
للكنيست من اجل اعطاء فرصه للوصول الى
اجماع بشان تشريع هذا القانون في الدوره
القادمه للكنيست
سنقوم بتمرير خطه اصلاح تعيد التوازن بين
السلطات الثلاثه من التعزيز حقوق الفرد
وانا هنا اريد ان اتوجه الى مؤيدي المعسكر
الوطني لدينا غالبيه في الكنيست يمكننا
بالقيام بذلك
بدعم هائل في الشعب العشرات من الالف من
مؤيدين وصلوا الى القدس لتاييد خطط
الاصلاح ليقولوا نريد تغيير نريد الاصلاح
اريد ان اقول لكم انا فخور بكم
انتم ليسوا مواطنين درجه ثانيه انا اقدر
خروجكم الى الشوارع
شوارع عاصمتنا لكي تسمعوا صوتكم
الديمقراطي صوتكم صوتنا
لن
يخمد احد هذا الصوت واريد ان اقول امر
وصلتم بشكل عفوي غير منظم غير ممول وغير
مدعوم الاعلام
وصلتم بقلبكم وبروحكم
واثرتم المشاعر لدي انا اطلب منكم شيء
واحد
يستمر بالتسرب مسؤوليه ولا تنجروا الى اي
استفزاز
طريقنا طريق الحقد غالبيه كبيره في
الجمهور
تعترف بضروره ادخال تعديلات في المنظومه
القضائيه لن
نسمع بان
ياخذ من الشعب قراره وخياره لن نتناسى عن
الطريق التي من اجلها ان تقبنا ولكن انسان
نبذل المحاوله للوصول الى تفاهم واسع
مواطنوا اسرائيل
نحن نعيش في جيل النهضه التاريخ
يعطينا فرصه خارقه فرصه لن تتكرر في تاريخ
الشعوب بان نعود الى وطننا ونبنيه ونبني
دولتنا
قريبا
سيحل عيد الفصح وايام الذكرى وعيد
الاستقلال
سنجلس الى طاوله الاعياد سويا نذكر
[موسيقى]
ضحايانا سويا
سنحتفل سويا وسنشكر
سويا النساء ورجال المنظومه الامنيه الذين
لم ينسوا لاي لحظه واجبهم في حمايتنا
جميعنا كل الوقت لان لنا جميعا يوجد مصير
ومشترك
هدف واحد وهذا الهدف هو
التامين ابديه اسرائيل
نعود مره اخرى الى ضيوفي من تل ابيب
دبلوماسي سابقه اسحاق لبنون ومن تل ابيب
ايضا روبين باركو الامني السابق ومن
الناصر عبر زوم وديع عواوده الكاتب
السياسي كنت اتحدث الى السيد باركو يعني
كنا نتحدث انه هذا الانقسام حاد الى اين
يصل اليوم يعني كما ترى نتنياهو يقول ان
هذه ازمه تهدد الوحده لاسرائيل
صحيح فيه هنالك تهديد للوحده الوطنيه
الاسرائيليه
لكن التهديد فعلا هو ما يقصده المعسكر
المحتاج الذي يعمل كل المظاهرات وهو اسكات
الحكومه وكاننا نتكلم عن الاصلاحات
القضائيه بينما هؤلاء الذين يدفعون
الجماهير الى الاحتجاجات والعنف في
الشوارع
هم يريدون فقط شيء واحد اللي هو
اسقاط حكومه وهو واعي لذلك ويريد ان يلقي
الضوء على موضوع التشريعات وكانه هو وكلنا
الموضوع هو يعني موضوع الاستصلاحات
التشريعيه وهو يعمل ذلك بحكمه لانه يراجع
بالجماهير الى
نقطه
الانطلاق المظاهرات وهي التشريعات ويؤجلها
قال بانه سيرجع تقديمها للكنيست منشاك
يعني شوف هو اكد على على شيء واحد وهو
يعني واقعيه ثابته ليس عليها اي جدال
[موسيقى]
فازت 64 مقعد اللي هي اغلبيه ساحقه مقابل
46 اذا ازلنا ولو للحظه ما الاحزاب
العربيه الغير صهيونيه فالمعسكر المضاد
يشمل فقط 46 مقعد في الكنيسه هذا خليه
ضئيله جدا ليس لها اي وزن بالنسبه للقرار
المنتخب الاسرائيلي فعلا اذا يعني نظرنا
وبحثنا
بسقوف بصفوف اخيره نرى اقليه
اريد ان تفرض رايها الاغلبيه الساحقه
بالتغليك غير ديمقراطيه من خلال اضرابات
من خلال تهديد على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
وعلى الجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا بحد ذاته عمل
غير ديمقراطي ولذلك استيقظ ممكن استيقظ
نتنياهو متاخرا في رده نتيجه طبعا عراقيل
قضائيه كانت ملقاعه
سابقا المستشار القانونيه منعته من الدخول
وسنه كانون خاص الذي ياتاح به
للمشاركه والالقاء الخطاب اللي شاهدناه
الان وارى من هنا نقطه التفات
تؤثر على الجماهير النقطه الاولى هي
تعجيل
بالنسبه للاصلاحات القضائيه الى الى ما
بعد الاعياد اليهوديه عيد الاستقلال
والذكر ى شهداء ذكرها نتنياهو طيب خليني
ادعم مجالي الى السيد ليبانون هل توافق
على ما ذكره السيد باركو
انا بكل صراحه يعني اولا هو زميلي وصديقي
ولكن انا اختلف مع اغاثه صحيح ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لديها
64 مقعدا في الكنيسه وهي اغلبيه يعني
ملموسه صحيحه قويه والى اخره ولكن حسب
رايي اسرائيل هو انه الازمه التي نواجهها
كانت اولا على مستوى الكنيست والمؤسسات
وهي نزلت الى الشارع الى شاعر الجمهور
ونحن نرى انه للجمهور عليه تاثير لذلك انا
اظن انه ما قام به السيد بنيامين رئيس
الوزراء باجراء هذه التعديلات الى فتره ما
هذه هي فرصه لعدينا ان نتخذها ونستغلها
لكي نصل الى حوار والى الوصول الى تفاهم
مع كل الجمهور لانه دوله اسرائيل هي دوله
واحده يعني في اراء مختلفه داخل اسرائيل
ويعني راي واحد ولكن هناك حاله انقسام هذه
يعني هذا الحاله الانقسام ما مرضها هل فقط
هي التعديلات التي يريد ادخالها على
القضاء ام هناك شيء اخر ابعد من ذلك لا
صراحه هي ابعد من ذلك ولكن في هذه الفتره
نحن نتحدث فقط على تعديلات القضائيه وهذا
هو كان النص الذي اتخذه الرئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو وانا حسب رايي اقرر من
جديد علينا ان ناخذ
ونجد فرصه انا اتكلم الى الطرف الثاني
التعديلات لكي نصل الى
رئيس الدوله
وندخل الغرفه هناك وكما في الفاتيكان لن
نترك هذه الغرفه بدون ان نرى انه اي نتيجه
ملموسه لكي اشترى الوقت الى هذه نعم هو
اشترى الوقت ولكن الازمه اذا كانت ابعد من
ذلك الى اين ما السبب الحقيقي في ذلك
السبب الحقيقي هو انه في اها مختلفه في
اسرائيل وفي شعور داخل
مثل كل دوله
اخر شاهدت في مصر كنت هناك عند الثوره
المصريه وهناك الشعوب عند الشعب والشعب
الاسرائيلي لديه شعور ولكن علينا
مهمه جدا
الجمهور حتى نفهم شعور بتهميشه سيد
ليبانون
في هنالك شؤون لكل شخص يعني
اذا تاخذه بصوره انفراديه ملك شعور عليك
ان نخرج
بناته ولكن علينا ان نفهم ان الشعب
الاسرائيلي بالرغم من المواقف
هو شعب متضامن وقوي داخليا
سيد اعتذر على التاخير ولكن يبدو ان هناك
ايضا كان اختلاف في الراي ما بين الزميلين
لكن اليوم اذا استثنينا الاحزاب العربيه
الاغلبيه كما اشار السيد باركو ماذا يمكن
ان يحدث نتنياهو من تغيير مستقبلي في حال
ارجاعه كما ذكر قبل قليل ارجاعه تقديم هذه
القوانين او الاصلاحات
نعم بدايه تحيه لك ولضيفيك اريد يعني
اشاره قصيره
لما ورد على لسان ضيفيك انا اعتقد ان
الازمه في اسرائيل اعمق مما تم تصويرها من
خلال ضيفيك كيف هذه هذه الازمه التي يعني
نشهدها الان هذه العاصفه الكبيره
صحيح يا دليل على مناعه الديمقراطيه في
اسرائيل وهذه المعركه على ابقاء النظام
الديمقراطي وهو بالاساس للاسف النظام
الديمقراطي لليهود من الناحيه الديمقراطيه
الجوهريه اكثر مما هو للمواطنين العرب
ولكن لندع ذلك جانبا انا اقول ان هذا
المشهد الاسرائيلي الان يتجاوز الخلاف على
مكانه محكمه العدل العليا وعلى فصل الفصل
بين السلطات الثلاث هذا تعبير عن تيارات
عميقه داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي خلافات
متراكمه تفجرت الان بين علمانيين ومتدينين
بين غربيين وبين شرقيين بين الدوله
العميقه وبين الدوله الرسميه حاليا الان
هناك صحيح في اعتبارات وحسابات سياسيه
حزبيه من كل الاطراف هذا صحيح ولكن هناك
يعني مشكله جوهريه حقيقيه هناك حاله تشضي
ولذلك سبق و صرح رئيس اسرائيل السابق في
مؤتمر المناعه القوميه في مؤتمر هيرسي عام
2015 في خطاب الاسباق حينما حذر من ان هذا
التظ بهذا الانقسام الداخلي هو اخطر من
قنبله ايران على اسرائيل انا انتظر يعني
ردود الفعل لرسائل معارضه على هذا الخطاب
اعتقد ان هذا الخطاب لن يكون مقبولا بشكل
كامل من قبل قاده المعارضه لانه فيه شيء
من المطبات فيه شيء من المخاطر في شيء من
المغامره اذا ما قبلت به لانه ببساطه ارجع
قانون واحد جوي صحيح ان هذا القانون قانون
تعيين
اللجنه التعيين القضاء ولكن هناك قوانين
اخرى كثيره لم يتم تنازل عن جوهر وفكره
التعديلات والاصلاحات الع في الجهاز
القضاء وفي النظام القضائي وفي النظام
السياسي لذلك ربما تكون هذه محاوله من
نتنياهو لاطفاء النار لمحاوله خفض حاله
التوتر والاحتقان والاحتدام خاصه وان فعلا
كانت الاوضاع في اسرائيل محتدمه جدا جدا
في ظل كل ما يجري وفي ظل هذه الانقسامات
التي تغلغلت الى داخل المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه لكن ينبغي هنا التاكيد ايضا
ان هذا الخلاف الاسرائيلي الداخلي يعني
يتجاهل او يكزن مشروعات قوانين تطال
الفلسطينيين وتستهدفهم على طرفي الخط
الاخضر مثل اذا من قصد نتنياهو بمواطنين
من الدرجه الثانيه هذا سؤالي لك بعد
الفاصل سيد عواوده
اذا نحن معكم في بانوراما وفيها بعد
الفاصل
ما هي السيناريوهات المطروحه والتداعيات
المتوقعه لما يجري في اسرائيل
[موسيقى]